Seth Davis from CBS I think he took
offense to people of my ilk who were
suggesting that maybe maybe the
committee has a sense humor and they
manipulate some of these games Seth
Davis joining us now
Danny Pugh how you doing good are you
upset that you know people have the
audacity to say maybe we're manipulating
it a little bit I'm in favor of them
doing this I would be too but hey I
would be too are we talking about like
the Patino yeah
a Minnesota Louisville thing or ordered
my dad a Marquette against Murray State
is it totally random that those two
games just came out of the hopper I
realized that people and by the way you
know what no one's talking about is if
Arizona State wins that's Bobby really
potentially planners of the school
Oakland Johnny Dawkins I think UCS and
Duke could be on on a track
this is very arcane nerdy stuff that
usually only people like me pay
attention to so you'll forgive me but
there's a lot of misconception about how
this works when the committee's in that
room they basically spend six days going
through everything every record to rank
the field one through 68 they're not
just doing the one two three four lines
all the way to 16 they're ranking all of
the teams 1 through 68 and that takes
like six days the placing the actual
placing of the teams in the regions and
into the brackets takes under an hour
which they probably do on Sunday to
incorporate Saturday results and it's
basically almost automatic because it's
driven mostly by geographies everyone's
mad that Michigan State's going to the
East but DC is closer than Anaheim so
that's where Michigan ends up going out
west so they can look every four lines
where they the overall seat totals are
totaled up so they can shift around for
a competitive balance if it looks off so
they tweak it here and there but mostly
it's pretty automatic and there's a lot
of principles about how many teams from
a conference can go here and whether
they played in the first round there and
certain things and whether or not you
know there's already somebody there's a
go to different reason but it's
basically driven by geography and it's
basically automatic so there's literally
no way even if you wanted to Dan
manipulate these matchups
you're looking at the teams 1 through 68
and you can't figure out where all of
that is gonna end up and so they
actually don't even see these matchups
until the ok bang we're done now we're
gonna look at a bracket so they don't
look at a bracket until they're
officially done so they don't have time
they don't have the inclination and they
literally don't have the ability to
manufacture matchups that's the truth
people don't want to hear it I don't
like to hear it every year we get these
intriguing storyline matchups of a coach
going against his 14 former team or a
dad coaching against a son or this or
that yeah it's just literally not
possible I'm sorry to spoil everybody's
fun and then you got LSU and Yale to
schools dealing with criminal
investigations it's too perfect not the
best scandal game ever okay what did the
committee get wrong well I'll tell you I
actually thought the Tennessee deserved
the number one seed over North Carolina
everyone you know knocked him everyone
said they were one seat until they lost
to Auburn in the final of the SEC
Tournament but unlike Carolina
unlike Michigan State they didn't have
any bad losses all their losses were the
top 20 net teams they beat Kentucky
twice including once on a neutral court
and they beat Gonzaga on a neutral court
so I actually feel like they had a case
for a 1 but I don't know Dan I feel like
this is one year where there just isn't
that much complaining about what they
did am I wrong I mean I checked the
order on Sunday night finally stayed
away from my own mentions I'm still
trying to do but you know I think the
fact that they put Belmont in the field
and by the way I'm not sure many people
picked up on this
they had UNC Greensboro in the field on
Saturday night and in Oregon winning the
pac-12 took away that spot so UNC
Greensboro was a first team out so so
they did which I've been advocating for
a long time sort of make room reaching
out to these mid major schools who have
proven over the years that they
absolutely belong in the tournament yeah
I watched UNC Greensboro when they were
playing Wofford and you know that was a
fun matchup I didn't realize that that
was going to probably cost them a chance
to get into the tournament a couple
other things is Duke too
asked me in three weeks I mean I'd
rather I'd rather be young and have Zion
than be old and not have science so I
don't I know they're not too young as
the answer but it's certainly something
they're going to have to overcome the
bigger problem with Duke Dan is there a
terrible 3-point shooting team this is
the worst 3-point shooting team HS he's
ever had if they win the national
championship they will be the worst
three-point shooting team ever to have
done that and they're also bad foul
shooting team next to last in the ECC so
I worry more about you know when we get
into a half-court type of game
possession by possession against a team
like a Michigan State or or Virginia or
even a you know good zaga Purdue you
know can they execute in the half-court
and of course you know foul trouble is I
and get to the foul trouble or there's
an injury but that's that's the case
with everybody but I'll also make the
argument that this could be the best
defensive team she says he's ever had if
you look at their metrics not only are
they top and efficiency blinds and
steals and all that stuff but they're
also in the top ten and fewest fouls
committed so they're doing all this
without fouling so every team is flawed
but certainly Duke has the best a game
in the field and you know they're my
pick to win at all but you know once
every I'm wrong once every seven or
eight years and maybe this is the year
that are wrong yeah I'm trying to figure
this out you know you start to look at
you got I don't I haven't filled it out
yet and I I don't reveal it until
Thursday know what happens I still have
to be talked in and out and in and out
again a couple of times before I fill
out my bracket so you know is the great
thing this is a great thing because they
this year I got hands at a bracket at
5:47 I almost had a heart attack on
Sunday waiting for the thing Clark does
not look at the bracket by the way
before the selection so he likes to
react to the teams as they come up so I
filled out my bracket in about eight
minutes and then got going on this so I
think that's the best way to do it I
would agree but I just love absorbing
all of this information because yeah it
feels like I can talk you in or out of a
pic and and it doesn't matter if it's
opening-round or you know the lead eight
or Final Four there's just so much
information and everybody's got an
opinion and that's what makes it fun but
I also look at you know when you start
to look at
is there somebody outside of the three
line that's gonna win the national title
because I talked to Godley yesterday I
said I got about six teams I think that
can win the national title do you have
more than six who you think legitimately
could win the title no I mean I would
say I would say eight I mean I I say it
always sort of felt like I think I'm not
positive damn I think if you go back to
like the early season brackets so we do
in February we have the same eight teams
on the top two lines I feel like Dean
those eight teams have really been the
ones who have been there all season long
and I do think that any of the eight are
capable of winning it so that would be
my my net but I'd be curious you know
one of your many staffs of researchers
to run the numbers on how many how many
teams seated below to have ever won a
national champions all bet it's what 15%
or less maybe maybe even less if the
seed defeating started in 1979 so it
doesn't happen that often it's almost
always gonna be ones and twos and I
think I think this year in particular
just feels like the ones and twos have
separated themselves all season long you
got a book out and tell us about that
it's uh you know you're dealing with
some of the big-name coaches here how
did this come about well this is at a
paperback now so it's called getting to
us how great coaches make great teams
I've got nine coaches profiled nine full
chapters six basketball three football
the basketball guys are Mike cesky Tom
Izzo Geno Auriemma
Jim Boeheim Doc Rivers and Brad Stevens
the football guys are Jim Harbaugh Urban
Meyer and Dabo Sweeney of Clemson and
you know all those guys gave me great
access to interview them and their
families and their wives and their
players and really just kind of you know
developing their life and their
leadership philosophy and you know to
get insights on how to persevere how to
persist how to develop your empathy and
how that applies to leadership so I had
a paper back today
yeah it's called getting to us how great
coaches make great teams we're talking
to Seth Davis CBS sports college
basketball analyst by the way I told the
story when I went to see To Kill a
Mockingbird aunt bird on Broadway and as
I got into the theater there
had a guy go hey you're tops on the
totem pole of the most famous person
here and I went I feel pretty good I'm
feeling pretty good and all of a sudden
I hear this I walked in know if you were
already there and then all of a sudden
Hillary Clinton walks down the aisle and
yet guy next to me goes you're number
two now then I hear this roar and then
Bill Clinton walks down and he goes I go
I got it all right all right down the
totem pole but I was back a little ways
so you got a chance to talk to President
Clinton and he wanted to talk college
basketball with you well it's funny
first of all I always write this on
Twitter when I'm on an airplane and
someone famous walks on I said this
famous person walked on like Joan Rivers
on my flight once it said if this plane
goes down I'm not definitely not in the
headline so that would have been the
same thing for us that night you know
many people probably know this my
father's Landing Davis he worked for
actually went to law school with both
Bill and Hillary back at Yale and worked
for in the Clinton White House for a
time and is now you know representing
Michael Cohen is very much so it was
total coincidence I was there with my
dad to see the Kill a Mockingbird which
is our favorite book so when they walked
in you know we're thinking you know what
we're gonna see them I said dad let's
leave them alone but we were we were
able to walk right down the aisle and
you know he kind of made our way there
and you know he said hi to her and and
him and I've met them both here and
there I've know them as well as he does
but as soon as Bill Clinton saw me he
jumped out of his seat and started
calling me on college basketball he's
probably listening right now try taking
notes on his practice and I was really
impressed with his knowledge and you
told me he really liked Gonzaga he's
actually pretty good friends with
Calipari I just talked to Calipari the
week before and was telling me about
that conversation and asking me my final
four and it kind of ignored my dad a
little bit so he's definitely you know
there's a difference between you know
someone who just might know or whatever
and someone who actually watches and is
a real fan he really really likes
college basketball is pretty cool and
then I turn around and I see you I'm
like this is like a great one of the
great nights of my life and and by the
way the play was really good as well
yeah yes the book is better though I
love that oh yeah I agree yeah but I
thought Jeff Daniels was was
really yeah maybe's great maybes fun all
right good luck on the road to the Final
Four and then I will talk to you along
the way and good luck with the the
reissue of the book Thank You Seth
having me Dan thanks guys all right Seth
Davis getting to us how great coaches
make great teams and he'll be part of
the studio team for more Dan Patrick
show to the audience channel 239 on
Direct TV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]